to kill its brand [ __ ] money butter
and white wait a min for their desk
right there fighting for their own lives
not I'm going to go out and kill does it
matter though it's noisy yeah what human
being would suddenly go ominous hi i'm
ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm thomas
welcome two reasons to see when we give
you reasons to see and not to see the
purge so let's purge reason to see
number one the concept yeah this one has
a brilliant [ __ ] concept i love it so
much it's cool because evil I'm I didn't
really care too much for this film I can
totally see them making a franchise out
of it like even focusing on another
group of people doesn't even have to be
a family you could just explore a
different group of people per movie
talking about people about horror flicks
especially and stuff like that people
always ask what is scary now a couple
days ago I just sat down to think about
this movie and I was like just as a
concept just the idea that for 12 hours
all crime is legal and no one can help
you that's like utterly horrifying to me
yeah I think it's really original I
think it's um it's not too crazy but you
kind of are thinking oh this might
happen you know in the near future it's
kind of not like outside the it's not
totally implausible the concept allows
for everything awful oh yeah you could
have two wives in America for 12 hours
we're gonna see number two Ethan Hawke
and Lena Headey yeah in every character
in this is is kind of a little
two-dimensional in some ways but the
these two actors really do elevate these
performances they bring a strong level
of humanity to it you believe them as
husband and wife I kind of like watching
that partnership work together I have a
lot of problems with with the script of
this movie but even when the script
wasn't good i still liked their
performances i thought they brought a
lot of they put their all into what's
going on you really believe these these
crises they're going through and then
how it's affecting them
and she has a great moment at the end a
moment where people were laughing but
it's the kind of thing where you're
laughing cuz you're kind of review for
her at the same time and when ethan
hawke you know sort of becomes Rambo at
some point that's pretty cool actually
everybody he first gets the shotgun
everyone in the theater was like what
the [ __ ] order where to get equipped
with that badass machine you know vision
to see number three love it he's called
like the polite strange yeah I saw that
on TV units yeah I thought he was more
creepy than anything is I think it was
more how intelligent he was because use
big words and like some that I didn't
really understand so whenever someone
uses big words that I don't understand
i'm getting a little creeped out by them
la there's they're smart yes smart cuz i
don't know what they're saying i thought
the guy did a really good job I mean for
villain roles like that I think they're
hard to execute because normally they're
just some guy who's like I devilish so
nice my and it looked like this but this
dude actually he could you could feel a
level of greedy depth behind this guy
bloodlust and all these underlying
layers and you can see how we sort of
like the leader kind of like the leader
of the posse at college or everybody
goes he came on-screen and I thought he
was captivating the whole time because
it's like you can tell that that
character fully believes in one this is
on you know on a level deeper than just
like oh I can do whatever I was like he
truly believes in the power of this
night reason not to see number one the
wooden dialogue yeah yeah especially
like the first 10 minutes it's like
purge tonight yeah purge tonight birds
tonight's a night say United be safe at
night because we have your security
system hey I say two cookies nice house
by the way that you expanded because you
got so much money installing all these
security systems are you purging oh no
we are not purging but we are like
because we know things will go run like
the whole reason we're here is because
there's a very dark concept and we know
something's gonna go wrong and I just
feel like the whole first half of the
movie is just sort of very thinly trying
to set up all things are great but
they're not gonna be for long and I just
feel like they could have used a punch
of writer to make things sound like
action
conversations I wouldn't say it first
time that was just more like the first
act recent got to see number two not so
scary yeah you know a lot of people who
see this trailer or hear the concept are
expecting this movie to be like
terrifying you know like it a lot of
people that's their anticipation so
that's why I think which is acknowledged
at it hey this film really isn't scary
yeah well it's not like you're dealing
with demons or you know monsters it's
not even really a horror movie yeah it's
yeah I mean it comes from platinum dunes
in bloom house yeah I kind of has its
creepy factors enjoy a okay like
skipping along and like long like dress
and their mass it's got sort of the
strangers yeah that's what I yeah
exactly the strangers yeah I mean
there's a creepiness underlying to it
but nothing really there that's gonna
you know make you [ __ ] your pants right
my panic split decision number one the
kid ok so I thought the kid was a was an
annoying [ __ ] I hated the kid I got one
kid one house knows how to do it since
get good kid actors yeah actors good the
kid is uh that's the wedding again
though I like that like yeah I don't
like the character at all I am it's like
his decisions throughout the movie we're
kind of like like you're smart I can
tell you're smart you created a baby toy
that can do so I can go around the house
and it kind of like a little of mobile
surveillance yeah a little kind of like
OCD factor phone no he's taking his
vitals like every couple minutes and
everything so he's kind of you know I
can kind of tell there's something up
with this kid by then finally he lets
the guy in the house yeah but he's she's
doing his bit like the year I understood
the kid like it would make no sense for
ethan hawke to live the guy in the house
but the kid is like struggling with this
whole idea like it's too big for his
mind to process and he sees a guy out
there just wanting to hide it or at
least as it seems just wanting to hide
so he's like this is a big distressing
idea to him already it's clearly a bit
much for him to handle so we let the guy
in I totally understood I think the key
he was just hits do [ __ ] like I think
you just put there just to be like how
was this guy gonna get in here okay
let's have this dumb kid make a stupid
decision that's gonna affect his entire
family and I've been really I didn't
really think that he would have done
that like he wasn't really rebellious
enough where I think he would have gone
against but it wasn't an act of
rebellion it was an act of compassion
toward another human being like the kid
is not the animal yet you know to the
kid it's like this guy is clearly being
chased by somebody he seems to just want
help like he's probably not the position
to go like but he might kill us we
should just leave him out there to die
like it's a morality here's why here's
why hit the kid it's all his fault why
all this happened yeah that's like a
really really short movie they would
have gotten through the purge next day
and everything good everything would
have been okay way back hey just if you
let the black guy just get turned over
everything would have been another
stupid moment these Miami said it with
the stupid kids yeah yeah I didn't
really think that you these are
compassionate kid and it does me I just
want you I don't think he's a [ __ ] i
means like he's God why I don't really
run either his whole family's gonna get
slaughtered or help save this one guy
and he's calm he's consistently putting
this one guy this stranger before his
family split decision number two the
daughter yeah the daughter to me was
just a typical whiny teenager she was
another stupid one to me you know I
agree with you on the writing side of
things I thought her performance was
fine I didn't really get too much from
her performance she knows of wines or
cry yeah I'm talking about the character
itself oh no like not so much to perform
the performance is fine just the
character could have been so much better
check it out had a bigger role in the
film yeah they could have just done much
better written out okay oh and she
brings the
split decision number three the first
half I like the first half a lot more
than a lot south I thought the first
half was were most of its originality
was at I like a movie that sets up a
world you know Twitter the first thing
it comes to music part for some reason
because in Jurassic Park they set up
this world of what if we can bring
dinosaurs back and then the first hours
posing the question of is this okay or
is this not okay and this poses a
similar question is this okay or is this
not okay you get to explore that debate
for like the first 20 minutes through
like people on the television some
people talking about it and then the
plot starts to then the story starts to
go and then there's more originality and
there's more originality but then the
last stop is when I thought I'd just
took a whole other term but the first
half is the part I respected the most
yeah I mean they do set up a world which
is really cool it's the whole reason
people want to see this is because it's
unique it's 0 and then I think they
really could have played on that more
than you know having just something
going on in the house I think they they
set up this world they should have
elaborated on the world a lot more yeah
they set up a concept where you could
have a great debate about it there's
great philosophies that could be brought
up there's so many things more others
psychological elements and you only get
hints of that and you get moments of
that but it doesn't feel like it's
something that resonates throughout
however just as a movie going experience
I preferred the second half to the first
half because the first half it was like
I just all the setup just felt so kind
of thin and wouldn't it was only the
first act oh and there's still
originality in the first act yeah its
original but I thought the movie was
better at doing what it was doing in the
second part I mean the real reason I saw
I want to see the film was because it
was original and when it started getting
more into the home invasion kind of
split decision number for the last half
yeah like the last half to me was that's
when it just became a typical home
invasion movie it stops exploring its
concept it stops posing questions and
everything like that like I guess the
midpoint is when
there are movies that have I don't mind
a home invasion movie I don't but it's
when it just seems like a replicant
rather than not doing a more of a unique
spin on it it's it's frustrating when
you have such an original concept but
then the movie decides to kind of like
can a lot of that and just turn it into
something that is predictable full of
cliches and it's honestly loses a lot of
its thrills the thing for me is that i
get actually what you guys are saying
about the second half and it's not the
movie in and of itself has an original
concept it's got an original view of the
world that is very unsettling however as
a plot is just a story about people it's
not ultimately all that surprising there
are a few twists and turns but I think
the reason I like the second half a lot
is because I think the second half is
effective it's it's no workman like is
the wrong term I guess but it's like I
think they put every day just assembled
it well it's like
you're wrong by the way just i should
say yes my opinion is yeah the way you
the way I viewed the way you think and
feel is just wrong it's just not right
no yeah it's happened yeah yeah we can
hang out with you okay opinions are
based on our acting yeah they're not
entitled to your own opinion yeah no no
it's like you're horrible person yeah no
I'll take your opinion it's Ryan's
consensus there are a few reasons to see
the purge there are a few reasons to see
the purge yeah I like the concept enough
to be like you know what you might as
well go check it out because who knows
it might be what you're expecting
Jerry's consensus uh yeah I think there
are some reasons to see the purge there
are some reasons to see the purge uh
yeah the concept is cool that the cast
is really good I thought um and you know
there's some there's some tense moments
and some action in there so it's worth
checking out Thomas's consensus there's
a couple reasons to see the purge
there's a couple reasons to see the
perch if I could describe this movie in
one word I think it'd be man alright
guys thanks for checking out our show
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell us what would
you do on the perch anything is allowed
anything but don't say something's don't
ever trust an Internet moment for I'm
Allah I love people watch our show but
don't have her chest an internet comment
board to tell you what they would do if
there were no reason because your eyes
will melt out of your face I'm pretty
sure most internet comment boards are
already what would I do if there's no
rule the purge exists yes ah yeah it's
the Internet message board if you want
sugar more emphasis a reason to see you
click this link right here I watch you
go ahead click this link so you can
follow us on Facebook or click this link
Oh a little lower follow me right right
on twitter and if you want to get
updated every time a new review or a
video is out subscribe click on Thomas
it was pointing at his crotch right now
want to scroll down
yeah you wanna yeah quick that dick man
pretty big link alright this is good
though because it's proving a more equal
opportunity with every one of our guests
it's like it's either click boobs or
click a dick yeah every by some pretty
big tits too son you play don't like the
Arnold like uh I rather not because I
would rather you did here well I mean if
you're costing me to dip high on 400 is
that yeah they're liking you guys often
oh yeah I'm perching around
you